[Musique]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues j'ai le plaisir de saluer dans
la tribune d'honneur
une délégation
des mers et des représentants de
plusieurs communes
du Crès vive très menthuk konotope
de
Mario Paul qui a tant souffert de
ministres
et de Odessa
la délégation est accompagnée par notre
collègue Nadia sur le groupe président
du groupe d'amitié francs sucrées dont
je veux saluer l'extraordinaire
engagement de cette période
un invitation des maires de France et de
leur association les élus craignaient
ont participé hier congrès des maires
ils se sont entretenus aujourd'hui avec
les sénateurs du groupe d'amitié chers
collègues les communes ukrainiennes
victimes des bombardements ou occupés
par l'armée russe ont toutes été
durement éprouvés ils sont encore
aujourd'hui durement éprouvés elle joue
un rôle crucial dans l'accueil des
populations déplacées et l'organisation
de la résistance elle témoigne aussi de
l'unité de la nation ukrainienne
le trop nombreuses communes du crédites
ont été le théâtre et nous l'avons
mesuré notre délégation
au mois de juillet dernier ont été le
théâtre de Massac de crime que mis à
l'encontre de population civile ces
crimes un prescriptif devant être jugés
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le souligner
lors de ce déplacement à Kiev dans le
but de témoigner le mot en tout son sens
le mot témoigner de la solidarité du
Sénat à l'égard des autorités et du
peuple ukrainien les collectivités
territoriales français se sont mobilisés
dès la première heure pour venir en aide
à l'Ukraine agressée elles ont dans un
puissant élan de solidarité accueillez
des réfugiés participer à des convois
humanitaires c'était long de solidarité
fait honneur à notre pays
le développement des relations entre les
collectivités françaises et ukrainiennes
il s'agisse de partenariats ou de
jumelage va permettre d'ancrer dans la
durée les liens de solidarité entre nos
deux pays pour mieux reconstruire du
crâne et œuvrer en faveur de la paix
c'est le sens de votre présence mes
chers collègues aujourd'hui alors en
votre nom à tous permettez-moi d'assurer
nos amis Ukrainiens du soutien du Sénat
français dans leur combat pour la
liberté la souveraineté retrouvée de
leur pays merci
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance est retransmis en direct
sur Public Sénat et sur notre site
chacun aura à cœur
à respecter les valeurs qui sont
essentielles pour nous le respect des
uns et des autres mais aussi
[Musique]
la 38
e avec d'ores et déjà un constat les
restos du cœur accueilleront 12% de
personnes en plus par rapport à l'an
dernier à travers mon intervention je
souhaite aborder plus généralement la
question de la précarité alimentaire
celle qui touche d'après le Secours
populaire plus de 7 millions de nos
concitoyens face à cette crise le
secteur associatif essaye de pallier les
manquements de l'État mais malgré la
solidarité qui s'organise le contexte
économique qui fragilise les
associations faisant phase depuis
plusieurs mois à une augmentation des
charges de fonctionnement carburant et
énergie mais également à une
augmentation des coûts d'alimentation
leur action de plus en plus compliqué
dans tous nos territoires cette même
augmentation des prix de l'alimentation
conduit à une baisse des dons de
particuliers c'est donc toute la chaîne
de solidarité qui se trouve aujourd'hui
en difficulté dans le cadre de leur
mission d'action sociale et de lutte
contre l'exclusion les CCAS
interviennent au quotidien sous des
formes majoritairement financières
chaque est bon alimentaire je veux
d'ailleurs ici rendre hommage aux élus
locaux présents en tribus ou présents au
congrès des mers qui savent prendre leur
responsabilité écoutez accompagner
chacune chacun pourra leur apporter la
réponse dont ils ont besoin cependant
les budgets des communes sont de plus en
plus contraints par les politiques
d'austérité conduites par votre
gouvernement face à ce conseil une seule
question quant allez vous prendre la
mesure de l'urgence sociale qui touche
notre pays
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué
en charge des petites des moyennes
entreprises commerces artisanales
tourisme madame la ministre merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice cukermann merci pour votre
question qui me donne l'occasion de
revenir sur l'action du gouvernement
dans le contexte délicat que nous
traversons tous en Europe et en France
aussi même si vous le savez l'inflation
y est plus faible la plus faible de la
zone euro j'échange tous les jours avec
les responsables de la grande
distribution j'y étais encore ce matin
on partage avec eux le constat et
surtout le pourquoi plutôt que le
constat de ces hausses de prix et nous
avons
un rapport en main qui a été rendu
public il y a quelques semaines qui est
donc à votre disposition qui a été fait
par l'IGF qui a été remis à Bruno Le
Maire relan Lescure et moi-même
expliquant que même s'il est pris
augmentent pour certains produits de
façon importante soyons clairs il n'y a
pas eu de marge indus bien au contraire
madame la sénatrice Karman et des
efforts sont faits pour que les prix
soient le moins haut possible pour
autant la situation elle est complexe en
ce moment et c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement au-delà des 140 milliards
d'euros qui ont déjà été mobilisés à
taravaire différents dispositifs vous le
savez la mise en place du bouclier
énergie les remises à la pompe le
gouvernement continue à accompagner les
acteurs de l'aide alimentaire la
première loi de finance rectificative a
prévu vous le savez un effort
exceptionnel de plus de 50 millions
d'euros en faveur de l'aide alimentaire
en faveur des associations fragilisées
par la hausse des prix des denrées par
ailleurs le déblocage d'une enveloppe
exceptionnelle de 10 millions d'euros de
crédit d'aide alimentaire pour répondre
aux difficultés spécifiques de nos
étudiants ça va permettre le financement
d'au moins 300 000 colliers alimentaires
supplémentaires pour permettre à nos
étudiants de se nourrir dans ces moments
difficiles enfin la première ministre
jeudi 3 novembre dernier encore annoncé
la création d'un fond spécifique pour
une aide alimentaire durable dotée de 60
millions d'euros pour son amorçage en
2023 pour renforcer au-delà de la
quantité la qualité de l'aide
alimentaire la le gouvernement est sur
l'ensemble des réponses pour accompagner
nos associations et les plus fragiles je
vous remercie madame la sénatrice qui
Karman
satisfaisait d'un constat qui fait que
parallèlement les patrons du CAC 40 ont
doublé leurs revenus je ferai toujours
partie de celles et de ceux qui
combattront les inégalités pour donner
sens et cœur à la devise de notre
République la liberté l'égalité et la
fraternité pour que chacun puisse bien
vivre dans son territoire merci la
parole est à notre collègue Frédéric
marchand pour le groupe il y aura sur le
moment des démocrates progressiciens
indépendants vous avez la parole
président la présence des services
publics sur nos territoires et
particulièrement sur les territoires
ruraux est un sujet au cœur de bien des
échanges dans les allées du 104e congrès
des maires de France et à mon tour je
veux ici saluer celles et ceux qui sont
ploient sans relâche pour le quotidien
de nos concitoyens dès 2017 le président
de la République s'est engagé sur le
sujet cela s'est traduit concrètement
par la mise en place de 2400 maisons
France services 47 pour le sol
département du Nord et leur 4000
conseillers numériques les programmes
actions coeur de ville et petites villes
de demain 15 dans le Nord ainsi que la
mise en place de l'agenda rural autant
de programmes que l'Agence nationale
pour la cohésion du territoire anime et
pilote depuis leur lancement et je peux
y témoigner de la qualité du travail
mené entre tous les acteurs l'exemple de
la ville de Douai toujours dans le Nord
étant à cet égard révélateur de la
méthode partenariale mise en oeuvre et
qui se concrétise par des premiers
résultats salués par toutes et tous et
l'envie d'aller plus loin dans la
redynamisation du territoire la création
de 200 brigades de gendarmerie partout
sur le territoire grâce à la loi
d'orientation et programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur participe de ce
grand mouvement et l'ensemble des mers
est grande comme nous avons pu le
vérifier le 7 novembre dernier toujours
dans le Nord à Solesmes à lavitation du
ministre de l'Intérieur là aussi ce
travail a pour vocation d'être mené dans
un souci de partenariat de mutualisation
et donc d'efficacité au service de nos
concitoyens monsieur le ministre il
n'est pas de bonne série qui ne
connaissent pas de suite et les
programmes générés par la NT n'échappent
heureusement pas cette règle c'est
notamment le cas du programme Action
chœur de ville avec une saison attendue
avec grande impatience après le succès
du premier opus sobriété foncière
rénovation ternemique mobilité verte
sont autant de défis qu'on va relever
nos collectivités et la transition
écologique est sans conteste l'issue de
la cop27 en témoigne la priorité des
priorités car derrière la transition
écologique c'est un véritable choix de
société qui nous faut mener sans tarder
et l'échelle territoriale est évidemment
la plus pertinente pour l'engager je
n'oublie pas non plus les sujets de
santé qui nécessitent une mobilisation
de toutes les énergies monsieur le
ministre au lendemain ne vous
impatientez pas au lendemain de la tenue
des 5e rencontre nationale coeur de
ville pouvez-vous donc nous détailler
les priorités moyens mis en en oeuvre
pour conforter encore et toujours plus
l'impact de ces dispositifs dans les
villes moyennes et plus globalement à
l'échelle du territoire je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole communiste
déléguée en charge de la ville et du
Logement Monsieur Olivier Klein n'avait
la parole monsieur le ministre
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Frédéric Darmand
permettez-moi à tout d'abord d'excuser
Caroline caillou qui avec le président
de la République actuellement au salon
des mers je vous remercie de mettre
je vous remercie de mettre en avant ces
programmes si chers à la première
ministre et au président de la
République que sont actions au cœur de
ville petite ville de demain et les
maisons France service j'avais
d'ailleurs eu l'occasion d'inaugurer une
des premières avec le président de la
République à Amiens il y a quelques
années bien évidemment action cœur de
ville en particulier c'est un programme
qui marche c'est 234 communes comme vous
l'avez rappelé qui ont bénéficié des 5
milliards d'euros de ces programmes avec
l'État et nos partenaires financiers que
sont
la banque des territoires actions
logements et Lana et puis les
collectivités locales parce que les
programmes actions cœur de ville non de
sens que s'il y a l'impulsion des
collectivités locales plus de la moitié
de ces programmes d'ailleurs étaient
liés à des programme en rue et là encore
on a vu l'effet de levier de la cohésion
entre l'action cœur de ville et les
programmes de renouvellement urbain
78000 logements rénovés grâce à Sion
cœur de ville c'est important et c'est à
souligner et c'est ce qui va engager
comme vous l'avez dit action cœur de
ville 2 le deuxième opus comme vous
l'avez appelé qui sera effectivement un
programme particulièrement lié à
l'écologie parce que il faut être
attentif à la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments notamment des bâtiments
anciens au cœur de ville être attentif à
l'étalement urbain être attentif aux
friches et c'était déjà un des
programmes du programme de relance et
action cœur de ville sera aussi attentif
aux friches à la renaturation en ville
et tous ces programmes seront évidemment
aussi au cœur de petites villes de
demain qui sera un programme qui sera
prolongé avec pour action cœur de ville
5 milliards d'euros annoncé par ma
collègue Caroline caillou il y a
quelques jours je vous remercie
merci la parole et maintenant président
Patrick cannaire pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et République
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre sur le plan financier le climat
entre l'exécutif et les collectivités
territoriales et mauvais
chaque début de quinquennat va revenir
les mêmes méthodes après la taxe
d'habitation vous attaquez aujourd'hui à
la CVAE en 2022 comme en 2017 votre
formule reste la même aucune négociation
réelle avec les associations d'élus la
main de l'État recentralisateur s'abat
sans que les principaux concernés ne
leur mot à dire chaque fois que vous
appliquez votre dogme du mois d'impôt
les collectivités locales passent à la
caisse elle qui vote leur budget à
l'équilibre il faut le rappeler ne
veulent pas être les variables
d'ajustement de l'incurie budgétaire du
gouvernement il n'est pas acceptable de
fragiliser les collectivités et plus
particulièrement les communes qui ont
souvent pallier les carences de l'État
lors des crises précédentes il n'est pas
acceptable non plus d'opposer
artificiellement la dépense publique qui
pour vous ne serait qu'une charge à la
richesse créée par les entreprises les
collectivités territoriales créent
également de la richesse par le
dynamisme de leurs investissements elle
crée des emplois de service pérenne
qualifiés non délocalisables
service public de qualité sont un choix
de société le seul bien de ceux qui ne
possèdent rien la disparition programmée
de la fiscalité locale remplacée par les
dotations aléatoires de l'État et
contraire au principe de libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales nos 500 000 élus locaux
serviteurs de la République ont besoin
de respect de lisibilité aussi dans sa
sagesse et sa diversité le Sénat c'est
opposé à la suppression de la CVAE au
début de la semaine madame le Premier
ministre ma question est simple allez
vous revenir sur votre politique
d'asphyxie fiscal de nos communes
allez-vous respecter le vote de la
Chambre des territoires
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Patrick Kanner alors nous
partageons une conviction les
collectivités doivent être libres d'agir
et pour cela il leur faut des moyens
suffisants
mais monsieur le Président Cannet je
préfère les faits aux propos à
l'emporte-pièce je préfère la réalité
plutôt que les polémiques depuis 2017
depuis 2017 nous vous en déplaise l'État
a été au rendez-vous lors de la crise
sanitaire nous avons mobilisé 10
milliards d'euros pour soutenir l'action
essentielle des collectivités face à
l'explosion des prix de l'énergie nous
prenons des mesures fortes avec
l'amortisseur électricité avec le filet
de sécurité pour les collectivités
fragilisées au total ce sont 2,5
milliards d'euros qui doivent permettre
aux collectivités de faire face à la
flambée des prix de l'énergie et je vous
rappelle que près de 30 000 communes
pourraient comme les ménages comme les
très petites entreprises bénéficiaient
du bouclier tarifaire ce dispositifs ils
ont été conçus avec les associations
d'élus avec les parlementaires ils
pourront le cas échéant être adaptés
pour répondre à toutes les situations
alors monsieur le Président Kanner je ne
veux pas être désagréable mais je suis
obligé de vous rappeler que l'action
menée depuis 5 ans contraste avec celle
portée pendant le quinquenn de François
Hollande
avec une réduction massive avec une
réduction massive de la dotation globale
de fonctionnement à hauteur de 13
milliards d'euros une baisse
indifférencier qui aggravement fragilisé
l'investissement des collectivités de
notre côté pour la première fois depuis
13 ans nous augmentons la DGF alors oui
pour défendre le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages pour renforcer la compétitivité
des entreprises nous avons décidé de
supprimer la taxe d'habitation et nous
souhaitons supprimer la CVAE ces baisses
d'impôts au profit des ménages et des
entreprises seront naturellement
compensées avec un autre impôt plus
dynamique plus stable la TVA et depuis
qu'une partie de la TVA est versée au
collectivités cette ressource donne
largement satisfaction je n'ai jamais
entendu un élu regretté la dynamique de
la TVA et vous le savez la TVA permet
d'offrir à des territoires fragiles
croissance portée par la consommation
nationale au-delà des ressources aussi
et à la demande des associations d'élus
le gouvernement a soutenu le maintien du
mécanisme de revalorisation forfaitaire
des bases fiscales qui atteindra 7 % en
2023 c'est un gain de 2,8 milliards
d'euros pour les collectivités enfin je
le redis nous ne laisserons aucune
collectivité sans solution donc monsieur
le Président Kanner je mesure pleinement
les inquiétudes que la période que peut
créer mais plutôt que de rajouter de
l'inquiétude à l'inquiétude en tentant
de faire oublier votre action passée je
vous invite à travailler avec le
gouvernement pour améliorer notre
accompagnement
[Applaudissements]
tu es le président Kader
madame l'après-midi vous n'avez pas été
désagréable mais je ne serai pas non
plus désagréable en rappelant les
responsabilités qui étaient les vôtres
dans le quinquennat que vous avez
traités
[Applaudissements]
ça vole pas très haut je vous le
conseille mais vous n'avez pas été en
plus très très agréable à mon égard
madame la Premier ministre la vraie
question qui est posée ici devant les
maires qui nous écoutent c'est
finalement que votre dogme du moins
d'impôt ça n'a pas de prix à vos yeux ça
je l'ai bien compris mais ça représente
8 milliards 8 milliards de pertes de
pouvoir d'agir dans les caisses de
l'État et quand vous évoquez la DGF qui
augmente de 370 millions d'euros c'est
moins de 2% alors que l'inflation est
assise pour cent très honnêtement votre
réponse n'est pas satisfaisante votre
choix est fait vous sacrifiez les
collectivités territoriales
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre collègue Véronique Guillotin pour
le groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
et social européen
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
un grand nombre d'élus ma question porte
sur l'insécurité à laquelle ils sont
trop souvent confrontés et puisque
l'actualité nous a tragiquement rappelé
que cette insécurité touche tous les
représentants de l'autorité publique
j'aimerais avoir une pensée pour
l'inspecteur des finances publiques qui
a lâchement été assassiné lundi dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions
pour une part croissante de la
population le service public s'apparente
de plus en plus à un bien de
consommation courante entraînant
incivilité agression envers ceux qui
représentent l'état et les collectivités
territoriales les chiffres le confirment
plus de 1800 procédures judiciaires ont
été engagées depuis janvier pour des
atteintes aux élus un chiffre en hausse
constante mais toujours en deçà de la
réalité puisque la plupart des victimes
ne portent pas plaintes rien mais rien
ne justifie d'agresser ceux qui se
dévouent pour leur collectivité souvent
au détriment de leur vie personnelle et
professionnelles comme le dit c'est
justement le président Larcher a porté
de baffes spécifiquement dans les
petites communes qui manquent de moyens
les mers et les adjoints sont obligés
d'intervenir eux-mêmes sur des
situations parfois tendues ces insultes
menacent agression physique mettre l'élu
et sa famille dans une situation
d'insécurité inacceptable et contribue
au nombre croissants de démission le
groupe RDS par la voie des rigoles et
Nathalie Delattre à déposé deux
propositions de loi sur ce sujet depuis
la deuxième adoptée dernièrement à
l'unanimité au Sénat qui prévoit la
possibilité pour les assembler et
associations d'élus de se constituer
partie civil au pénal pour soutenir un
élu ou l'un de ses proches victimes
d'agression de dégradation de bien ou de
divulgations d'informations privées
madame la ministre comment garantir une
réponse pénale rapide systématique et
efficace comme demandé par le garde des
sceaux et enfin confirmez-vous ici le
soutien du gouvernement à la PPL porté
par notre groupe pour qu'elle soit
adoptée à l'Assemblée nationale et
s'applique sans délai
pour vous répondre la parole le
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
citoyenneté madame Sonia bacchèche vous
avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président
la terre madame la sénatrice Guillotin
chaque fois qu'un élu est agressé c'est
la République qui est attaquée
depuis début 2022 c'est une centaine
d'atteintes chaque mois et ce sont
principalement les élus locaux ce qui
vaut au contact ceux qui sont les plus
proches de la population qui sont les
plus touchées il en va maintenant de
notre responsabilité collective pour
faire évoluer les choses responsabilité
collective dans l'éducation de nos
jeunes au respect de nos institutions à
l'école et par les parents
responsabilité collective en dénonçant
de manière systématique c'est fait et
responsabilité collective en ne
banalisant jamais
pardon jamais c'est fait commis contre
nos élus
je voudrais saluer madame la sénatrice
l'adoption à l'unanimité
à je vais y arriver
l'adoption à l'unanimité de la PPL qui a
été déposé pour permettre aux
associations d'élus de se porter et
partie civile pour soutenir au pénal les
élus qui sont atteints par ces
agressions c'est une avancée
significative qui a été possible par un
travail conjoint entre le gouvernement
en particulier
Eric Dupont-Moretti et Caroline cailleux
qui ont travaillé avec le groupe RDSE
pour rendre cette PPL possible on a le
gouvernement souhaite que cette PPL puis
cette portée également à l'Assemblée
nationale je rappelle que depuis 2019 et
la loi engagement et proximité qui a été
portée par Sébastien Lecornu nous avons
il y a un engagement pour les communes
de prendre des garanties pour assurer le
soutien aux élus en matière de soutien
psychologique en matière de protection
fonctionnelle en matière de conseil
juridique pour répondre à votre question
sur le pénal 100% des 203 suspects qui
ont été poursuivis ont fait l'objet la
réponse pénale
90 92% pardon on fait l'objet de
poursuites au tribunal et le Garde des
Sceaux a souhaité un dialogue de
proximité avec les élus avec 2000
contractuels qui ont été recrutés pour
assurer le lien avec les élus et donc
vous avez la confirmation de
l'engagement du Gouvernement sur ce
sujet merci
quelques secondes
quelques secondes nous avons bien
entendu madame la ministre et merci en
tout cas pour le fait de d'appuyer cette
PPL il y va effectivement de notre de la
survie de notre pacte républicain et de
notre cohésion sociale de ne plus
laisser un tel acte un puni merci
la parole est à notre collègue Renault
Dantec pour le gros écologie solidarité
et territoire
mais merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Madame Bérenger
Couillard secrétaire d'État chargé de
l'écologie madame la ministre la cop27
est de nouveau un échec même si cette
coque a permis le lancement d'un fond
spécifique pour répondre aux pères et
dommages des pays les plus vulnérables
elle n'a pas permis d'avancer sur un
scénario crédible de stabilisation du
climat sous les deux degrés en effet
alors que la COP de Glasgow avait appelé
à une rêve évaluation
urgente des engagements des états très
peu sont venus en Égypte avec de
nouvelles propositions en remontant très
légèrement ses propres objectifs moins
57% en 2030 au lieu de
-55%, l'Union européenne a néanmoins
rappelé son rôle moteur dans cette
négociation cet objectif européen nous
engage nous oblige à une réduction
massive de nos émissions cette réduction
passe obligatoirement par la
mobilisation des territoires à travers
en particulier les Plans Climat air
énergies territoriaux les PC et le Sénat
a d'ailleurs voté hier quasi uneanimité
la mise en place d'une dotation climat
systématique sur la base de 10 euros par
habitant pour permettre au bloc communal
d'accélérer dans la transition
écologique l'état de son côté annonce un
fond vert de 2 milliards la somme peut
sembler importante mais si elle n'est
qu'une liste de projets elle restera
néanmoins un saupoudrage aussi madame la
ministre ma question est très précise et
simple êtes-vous prêt à entendre le
message unanime du Sénat le vote d'hier
pour transformer une partie du fond vert
en dotation climat annuel systématique
qui donnera enfin au territoire de vrais
moyens de fonctionnement pour animer
leur transition et permettre à la France
d'atteindre ses objectifs climatiques
répondre la parole est à la secrétaire
d'État on cherche de l'écologie la
Bérangère Couillard madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur les
sénateurs dans tech l'accord de la cop27
préserve l'essentiel il maintient
l'objectif de limiter le réchauffement
climatique à 1,5 degrés réaffirmer cet
objectif de 1,5 degrés était essentiel
dans un contexte mondial de crise
énergétique où la tentation aurait été
grande de renoncer l'Union européenne
avec l'objectif de -57% des émissions en
2030 que vous rappelez montre la voie au
niveau mondial nous français et européen
ne pouvons que regretter que nos appels
allaient plus loin à la Coop sur les
efforts supplémentaires de réduction au
niveau mondial et la sortie des énergies
fossiles n'est pas été entendue vous
m'interrogez sur les moyens que nous
mettons en face de nos objectifs
climatiques en particulier sur le fond
vert le fond vert est un outil inédit en
matière de financement de la transition
écologique c'est un outil entièrement
dédié aux collectivités territoriales il
traduit notre conviction que la
transition psychologique ne pourra se
faire sans un rôle moteur des
territoires 2 milliards d'euros sont
prévus vous l'avez rappelé en 2023
l'intégralité des crédits sera engagée à
l'année prochaine ce sont des crédits
qui s'ajoutent aux dotations de coup
droit commun des cils DETR rappelez que
le budget du ministère l'année prochaine
c'est plus de 40 milliards d'euros et
c'est une hausse de 8 % par rapport à
2022 et c'est un fond qui vise à aller
financer les collectivités les moins
outillées pas d'appel à projets ou
d'appel à manifestation d'intérêt des
financements d'ingénierie pour aider les
collectivités à monter leurs projets
c'est un fond déconcentré intégralement
fongible qui permettra de s'adapter aux
besoins de chaque territoire on décidera
pas à Paris des critères d'octroi des
subventions on fera confiance au
territoire les priorités ont été
arrêtées sur la base des échanges que
nous avons eu avec les collectivités et
les services bien sûr de l'État dans les
territoires par exemple rénovation des
bâtiments publics recyclage des friches
soutien au et la valorisation des
biodéchets remplacement de l'éclairage
public encore la renaturation des villes
l'accompagnement à la mise en place des
ZFE les remontées que l'on a du terrain
sont prometteuses les collectivités se
montrent intéressées par cet outil et
nos échanges lors du Salon des mers le
confirme et les préfets et les services
des concentrés sont prêts aussi à se
saisir de cet outil dès le 1er janvier
alors je vous réponds monsieur le
sénateur se font vers c'est une dotation
annuelle pour financer l'action des
collectivités en faveur de la transition
écologique
oui madame la ministre s'il n'y a pas de
crédit de fonctionnement il n'y aura que
peu de projets et ça ne sera comme les
thèmes CV sans efficacité en termes
quantitatif tous les réseaux de
collectivités territoriales unanimaux
ont proposé cette dotation climat depuis
maintenant 5 à 6 ans elle a été vraiment
travaillée en profondeur ça correspond à
l'attente des territoires vous mettez
aujourd'hui 2 milliards sur la table que
c'est 2 milliards correspondent aux
demandes des réseaux de collectivités
tout simplement si
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue à la
marque pour le groupe des indépendants
République et territoire mais la parole
la ministre délégué chargé des petites
et moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme à la veille
du Black Friday période au cours de
laquelle les échanges commerciaux
intensifient je souhaite vous alerter
sur les dangers de nouveaux vecteurs de
la contrefaçon les influenceurs et la
nécessité de lutter contre leur pratique
illicites sur les réseaux sociaux si le
volume de la contrefaçon est difficile à
évaluer s'agissant d'une activité
clandestine par nature la Cour des
comptes estime raisonnable pour 2019 de
parler de 10 milliards d'euros de pertes
fiscales pour l'État et de plus de 40
000 emplois détruits chaque année le
phénomène de la contrefaçon qui a connu
un essor considérable au cours de cette
décennie menace potentiellement toutes
les entreprises fragilisant leurs
efforts d'innovation et d'investissement
et payant leurs actifs immatériels il
peut porter gravement atteinte à la
sécurité des consommateurs lorsqu'il
conc des médicaments des pièces
détachées automobiles ou des jouets il a
également un impact néfaste sur
l'environnement depuis peu les réseaux
sociaux médias incontournables du
marketing numérique offre un nouveau
cadre à la contrefaçon la simplicité
d'utilisation de ces supports numériques
donne l'opportunité aux internautes mal
intentionnés de promouvoir et de
commercialiser des produits de
contrefaçon en toute discrétion en effet
l'utilisation de ces médias grâce
notamment à la fonctionnalité des
stories au caractère éphémères
permettent aux influenceurs contre
facteurs de proposer à la vente des
produits de contrefaçon dont ils
assurent la promotion à l'insu des
titulaires de droit madame la ministre
la France ne dispose toujours pas d'une
stratégie nationale de lutte contre la
contrefaçon malgré les recommandations
de la Cour des comptes face à la
croissance exponentielle d'une nouvelle
forme de contrefaçon sur les réseaux
sociaux pouvez-vous nous indiquer les
mesures que vous envisagez de prendre
afin de lutter activement contre le
phénomène des influenceurs contre
facteur
quand vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge des petites
des moyennes entreprises et du commerce
d'un olivier Grégoire merci monsieur
le sénateur marre vous alerter en effet
sur une pratique de plus en plus près de
vous dire juste quand même pour ce qui
concerne la France en 2021 en matière de
contrefaçon ce sont quasiment un peu
moins de 10 millions de tonnes
d'articles contrefaits qui ont été
retirés du marché en particulier dans un
secteur spécifique celui des jouets et
des cosmétiques vous interpellez
l'attention du Gouvernement sur le sujet
de la contrefaçon et notamment son
développement en ligne et de la
responsabilité des influenceurs vous
dire que l'OCDE a récemment tenté de
quantifier là aussi le phénomène de
contrefaçon et pour vous donner un une
donnée de importante nous avons à peu
près 3,3% des échangements du haut de
marchandises et jusqu'à 6% des
importations de l'Union européenne qui
sont concernées par ces contrats
contrefaçon pardonnez-moi des chiffres
colossaux que je voulais partager avec
vous vous dire que la France est la
plupart des États membres de l'Union
sont touchés de la même façon par une
offre de croissante de contrefaçon en
ligne pousser effectivement vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le sénateur par
l'apparition de liens cachés ou de
postes qui sont masqués alors même
qu'ils sont sponsorisés mais ce
sponsoring et se soutien financier n'est
pas assumé et nous avons aujourd'hui pas
mal de mise en vente d'articles
contrefaisants qui peuvent être même
dangereux pour la santé je pense
notamment à l'arrivée de Noël aux jouets
et à l'impact sur nos enfants cette
façon de procéder est un qualifiable et
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
ministre de l'économie est des finances
Bruno Le Maire a annoncé et nous le
ferons dans les prochaines semaines
Bruno Le Maire s'y est engagé à ce que
nous nous accueillons l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés dont les influenceurs
monsieur le sénateur Marc à Bercy afin
de bâtir ensemble une stratégie et de
les engager en matière de responsabilité
sur le sujet des contrefaçons donc un
sujet avec le ministre de l'économie va
prendre à bras le corps d'ici quelques
semaines une consultation est prévue et
nous agirons en 2023 je vous remercie
quelques secondes merci la parole est à
notre collègue Christine beaufonti
dossard pour le groupe les républicain
[Applaudissements]
elle s'appelait Vanessa elle avait 14
ans
ce samedi 18 novembre elle rentre du
collège pour gagner le domicile de ses
parents à Tonneins vit le Cher au
sénateur Moga dans notre département du
Lot-et-Garonne au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment
vanessa est enlevé violet étranglé par
un individu connu des services de
justice pour des faits antérieurs commis
lorsqu'il avait 15 ans
il avait alors été condamné à 15 jours
d'emprisonnement a sorti d'un sursis
avec une mise à l'épreuve de deux ans il
n'était pas abstrait ni à aucun contrôle
judiciaire à aucun contrôle par une
association de d'insertion et de
probation il n'était pas non plus
inscrit au fichier d'auteurs
d'infractions à caractère sexuel et
pourtant
c'est grâce au visionnage de la vidéo
surveillance de la ville qu'il a pu être
interpellé rapidement monsieur le
ministre le Lot-et-Garonne est en deuil
un deuil d'autant plus cruel que c'est
la troisième petite fille qui est
enlevée sur le chemin de l'école
elle s'appelait Vanessa elle avait 14
ans monsieur le ministre c'est davantage
la vice-présidente de l'association La
Mouette association de prévention de
l'enfance qui vous interpelle et plus
que d'une question c'est un appel au
secours monsieur le ministre votre
gouvernement est-il prêt à donner plus
de moyens à la justice pour assurer un
contrôle réel et efficace à l'endroit de
ces individus votre gouvernement est-il
prêt à aider tous nos villages toutes
nos villes afin que toutes nos écoles et
tous nos collèges soient équipés de
caméra et puis monsieur le ministre vous
parlez souvent du principe de précaution
monsieur le ministre êtes-vous prêt à
ouvrir enfin les portes de l'éducation
nationale afin que les associations de
prévention de l'enfance puisse faire
leur première mission de prévention afin
de sauver notre bien le plus précieux la
vie de nos enfants merci
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre
délégué sur du nouveau démocratique
porte-parole du gouvernement monsieur
Veyron merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Christine bonfantie
dossard je ne peux pas commencer cette
réponse sans évidemment m'associer et
associé le gouvernement la douleur de la
famille à la douleur des proches des
camarades de classe de la petite Vanessa
de la population du Lot-et-Garonne et
puis généralement de la douleur que
chacun d'entre nous concitoyens français
à ressenti lorsque nous avons appris
qu'une fois encore une gamine une petite
une ado avait été enlevée victime de
sévices sexuelles et assassiné
pour commettre un acte monstrueux il
faut quelque part être un monstre
il faut pas avoir peur des mots quand on
s'en prend à une ado de cette manière là
de sang froid quand on décide de
l'enlever
vous m'interrogez sur le passé
judiciaire madame sénatrice il y a une
enquête qui est en cours évidemment je
ne peux pas me permettre de commenter
une enquête qui n'a pas encore révélé
tous ces mystères tous ces secrets je
peux néanmoins vous assurer que
procureur magistrat à force de police
avec la même détermination que celle que
nous mettrions vous ou moi si nous
étions en charge à cette enquête tout
sera fait pour que les solutions puisque
les réponses puissent être apportées à
la famille c'est ce que nous leur devons
madame la sénatrice vous interrogez le
gouvernement sur la possibilité pour des
associations de luttes contre les
violences faites aux enfants de rentrer
dans l'enceinte de l'école c'est le cas
c'est possible les directeurs
d'établissement sont habilités à
accepter l'intervention de telles
associations et madame la sénatrice ce
drame intervient et vous m'interrogez la
semaine ou la première ministre a réuni
un comité interministériel à Matignon
sur la question de l'enfance avec
Charlotte COBAL secrétaire d'État chargé
de l'enfance et de nombreux ministres
dont l'intérieur et le ministère de la
Justice et la première des priorités la
première des trois grandes priorités
c'est la lutte et la prévention de la
violence faite contre les enfants la
violence physique la violence verbale la
violence morale la violence numérique le
combat qui est le vôtre nous le
partageons madame la sénatrice je salue
votre action au sein de votre
association
ce dont nous parlons là n'est pas
politique n'est pas politisée
en revanche ce qui est un peu plus
politique c'est le choix que nous avons
fait depuis plusieurs années parce qu'il
le fallait d'augmenter comme ça n'avait
jamais été le cas auparavant les moyens
pour que la justice puisse passer mieux
et plus vite croyez que nous
continuerons merci la parole est à notre
collègue Jean-Pierre Moga pour le groupe
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la première ministre
mesdames Messieurs le ministre mes chers
collègues
qu'on me vient de le rappeler ma
collègue Christine Bonfanti vendredi
dernier Vanessa 14 ans était assassiné à
Tonin ville donc j'ai été le maire
pendant 13 ans avec pudeur émotions au
nom de notre assemblée je tiens tout
d'abord à exprimer notre solidarité
envers les parents de Vanessa
je les ai rencontrés ce sont des gens
admirables ils sont venus dans notre
pays pour y travailler
ils ont malheureusement trouvé ce qu'il
y a de pire pour des parents face à
l'horreur ce sont toujours les mêmes
questions qui reviennent que s'est-il
passé cela aurait pu être évité à qui la
faute ces questions je me les pose je
vous les pose mais en passant en revue
les circonstances du drame il est bien
difficile de répondre d'y répondre à ce
problème un problème d'immigration ou de
radicalisation pas du tout l'hôtel
présumé des faits n'a rien de l'étranger
physicien une faute de la gendarmerie
absolument pas les gendarmes ont été
très réactifs et ont immédiatement pris
la situation au sérieux une insuffisance
de moyenne municipaux de sécurité encore
moins j'en sais quelque chose c'est moi
qui est initié les caméras à Tonneins
bien sûr des voies ne manqueront pas de
s'élever pour réclamer toujours plus de
caméra toujours plus de surveillance
mais jusqu'où pousser l'assurance cher
ne risque-t-on pas de basculer dans une
société dont personne ne veut alors il
reste une dernière piste je vous la
soumet ma collègue là évoqué l'assassin
présumé avait déjà commis une attelle
pas un défaut de suivi psychologique
médical et judiciaire même si les faits
remonte à ses ans
monsieur le ministre qu'en pensez-vous
et que pensez-vous que pensez-vous faire
pour que de telles faits ne se
renouvelle pas je vous remercie
que le ministre
[Applaudissements]
porte-parole du gouvernement monsieur
Véran
monsieur le Président Madame et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jean-Pierre Moga d'abord
encore une fois m'associer à la douleur
de toute la population des élus des
gendarmes de la famille évidemment vous
demandez en fait à travers votre
question s'il est possible de nous
insérer nous immiscer nous projeter dans
le cerveau d'un individu qui adulte
décide de s'en prendre à des enfants de
la pire des manières je vous avoue les
limites de l'exercice j'en suis
incapable j'ai pourtant exercé la
psychiatrie comme interne la neurologie
je connais parfois les profondeurs noirs
des esprits humains je connais parfois
les ravages que peuvent faire certains
troubles mentaux je ne crois pas
l'enquête le dira mais que cette
personne était de nature à justifier
d'un suivi psychologique ou
psychiatrique en tout cas c'est pas ce
qui avait été décidé manifestement
lorsqu'il avait 15 ans maintenant vous
l'avez dit vous-même c'était il y a 16
ans
ce genre de daktabject monstrueux je le
redis
nous pose des questions nous interroge
parce que c'est la barrière même de la
notion d'empathie d'humanité de rapport
à l'autre qui est
percuté à grand coup de pied quand on
s'en prend un enfant comme cet homme
s'en est pris un enfant et évidemment à
chaque fois qu'un drame comme celui-ci
intervient en charge des réponses je ne
sais pas si on trouvera les réponses
dans le cerveau de cette personne y
compris à l'issue de l'enquête en tout
cas nous aurons les réponses sur ce qui
lui a permis de réaliser cet acte sur
qu'il a conduit à régler cet acte et à
travers ses réponses on trouvera des
moyens si c'est nécessaire de renforcer
tout ce qui est acte de prévention de
contrôle de surveillance pour éviter que
ces drames terribles qui peuvent
émailler notre pays ou d'autres pays
soit amené à revenir à resurgir est-ce
que c'est un enjeu de surveillance
honnêtement je n'en suis pas sûr mais
sans les éléments complets de l'enquête
mais difficile de vous répondre sur ce
point mais à nouveau sachez que la
détermination est totale des services de
justice et de police et du gouvernement
et la représentation nationale non pas
pour comprendre ce que le cerveau nos
cerveaux humains ne peuvent pas
comprendre mais faire en sorte que ça ne
se reproduise plus jamais
merci monsieur
collègue Mathieu d'Arnaud pour le groupe
les républicains
madame la Première ministre les maires
sont inquiets inquiets devant une
situation économique aussi inattendu que
brutale l'inflation
ose drastique du coup des énergies
os des produits alimentaires qui pèsent
sur le budget de nos cantines scolaires
ou encore la hausse du point d'indice
devant cette situation la réponse du
gouvernement et trop timide voire peu
opérante trop timide comme la hausse en
2022 de la DGF qui ne masquera pas une
baisse tendancielle ni même ne permettra
de juguler l'inflation peu opérante
c'est le cas du filet de sécurité on a
vu que les ambitions étaient fortes et
qu'à l'arrivée peu de communes pourront
bénéficier en 2022 de ce filet de
sécurité le Sénat dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
jouera son rôle pour essayer d'ouvrir le
champ des communes éligibles au filet de
sécurité mais notre inquiétude ne
s'arrête pas là madame la Première
ministre
inquiétude c'est aussi vos propos
lorsque vous appelez finalement
à privilégier le lien entre les
présidents d'intercommunalité et les
préfets où sont les maires dans tout ça
notre inquiétude c'est aussi l'absence
ou la faible réaction du gouvernement au
préconisations de la Cour des comptes
qui invitent à ce que la DGF soit versée
aux intercommunalités alors ma question
madame la Première ministre elle est
très claire croyez-vous encore en la
France communale et si tel est le cas
nous attendons comme les mères des
preuves d'amour
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge de la ville
et du Logement monsieur Klein
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur d'Arnaud comme la première
ministre vous la rappelez tout à l'heure
face au défi inédit auquel font face les
collectivités territoriales le
gouvernement est au rendez-vous il est
un rendez-vous il est au rendez-vous
pour les aider maintenir leur capacités
d'investissement cela est fait en
concertation avec les associations
d'élus pour qu'on construire les
solutions au plus proche du terrain vous
pouvez aussi avoir confiance aux anciens
maires que nous sommes Caroline cailleux
Christophe vichu et moi-même pour être
particulièrement attentif à ces
questions et nous sommes nous aussi des
élus locaux attachées à notre territoire
je vous dire en premier lieu que le
gouvernement et la majorité peuvent être
fiers des mesures proposées dans le PLF
en faveur des collectivités locales
comme la rappeler madame la Première
ministre avec pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans une augmentation de la DGF
de 320 millions d'euros face à face à
l'inflation nous avons un mécanisme
complet qui permettra plus de 95%
d'avoir une DGF maintenu ou augmentée et
vous le savez vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
l'État va aussi soutenir les
collectivités locales en particulier les
plus fragiles face à la hausse des
énergies avec les différents boucliers
tarifaires que nous avons mis en place
c'est plus d'un milliard d'euros qui
seront destinés à ce à cette action et
sur les questions liées à la
décentralisation que vous évoquez à la
fin de votre question le président de la
République l'a rappelé c'est un sujet
qui sera mis en débat avec l'ensemble
des collectivités locales des
associations et comme le disait madame
la Première ministre vous invitons à
écouter son discours demain au salon des
mers merci
monsieur d'Arnaud
est totalement éludé la question sur
l'avenir de la France communale mais ça
je m'y attendais mais nous avons en
partage madame la Première ministre
cette volonté de prêter plus d'attention
aux actes commaux or c'est bien de cela
dont il est question et nous attendons
et si on regarde le filet de sécurité on
pensait qu'il y aurait 22 000 communes
qui seraient éligibles et qui pourraient
bénéficier de ce filet de sécurité en
2022 on sera largement en dessous des
10000 donc mettez en application vos
propos passer aux actes merci
la parole
est à notre collègue victoire jasmin
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
si monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
ma question s'adressait au ministre des
Outre-mer il n'est pas là
c'est dommage monsieur le ministre comme
vous le savez en cette période de
congrès des mères la MF réserve par
tradition la première journée aux
outre-mer
tant de problématique sont nombreuses en
matière institutionnelle en matière de
précarité de culture et d'économie son
spécifiques et requiert des adaptations
par rapport à l'Hexagone pour autant
comme en hexagone les collectivités
locales sont essentielles au vivre
ensemble au Bien Vivre Ensemble trop
souvent mis à mal dans ses territoires
éloignés par une défiance originelle
vis-à-vis de l'État et de l'autorité or
les collectivités territoriales
d'outre-mer qui pâtissent déjà bien sûr
financement chronique d'une masse
salariale très importante et d'un coup
de la vie 30% plus cher doivent elles
aussi faire face à l'inflation sur les
matières premières et sur l'énergie
c'est dans ce contexte de grande tension
que le gouvernement a consenti a des
efforts supplémentaires en faveur du
budget d'une première bien qu'il
suffisant une année en moins appréciable
pour autant qu'il soit intégralement
exécuté
7 ans cette sous-exécution font
d'ailleurs l'une des mises en garde
durée sans rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui demande que les engagements
de l'État soient mieux suivis avec une
appui et une ingénierie locale en vue de
meilleures utilisations les crédits à
louer au collectivités d'outre-mer ces
dernières bien sûr son volontaires pour
plus d'accompagnement et de
contractualisation preuve en est la
Guadeloupe compte plusieurs communes qui
ont bénéficié du contrat de redressement
en outre-mer déjà mis en place dans
certaines communes et bien aujourd'hui
il est nécessaire de faire une extension
mais pour que ce soit un peu plus
flexible beaucoup d'autres communes
envisagent de contractualiser avec le
gouvernement ainsi Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelles
mesures d'ajustement envisagez-vous de
prendre pour élargir les couronnes et à
plus de communes volontaire donner plus
de moyens d'action au maire des
outre-mer pour sans oblitérer évidemment
leur autonomie je merci et pour la
parole est au ministre délégués en
charge de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications monsieur Jean-Noël
Barrault
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice victoire jasmin permettez-moi
d'abord d'excuser l'absence de mon
collègue Jean-François caranco qui est
actuellement avec le président de la
République au Salon des Maires auprès
d'éluses
ultra marin permettez-moi ensuite de
témoigner de la solidarité du
gouvernement à l'égard du conseil
régional de Guadeloupe frappé par une
cyber-attaque d'ampleur qui paralyse un
certain nombre de ses services aux
populations j'ai eu le président Harry
chalut au téléphone et les services de
lancies sont en lien étroit avec les
services du conseil régional pour
apporter des solutions une remédiation à
cette attaque les contrats de
redressement outremer les corums cités
dans votre question dit contrats patient
Cazeneuve et saluons le sénateur Georges
patient pour ce travail ont été lancés
en 2021 le dispositif comme vous le
savez visait accompagné les communes
ultramarines faisant face à des
difficultés financières 9 communes sont
aujourd'hui contractantes et s'engagent
à optimiser en gestion et fiabilisée
leurs comptes il s'agit de Sada Mayotte
Saint-Benoît à la Réunion Cayenne et
irakubo en Guyane Pointe-à-Pitre
Saint-François et Basse-Terre en
Guadeloupe et Fort-de-France et
Saint-Pierre à la Martinique il s'agit
d'un partenariat gagnant-gagnant la
collectivité s'engage sur une
trajectoire financière de redressement
d'amélioration de gestion l'état apporte
des subventions de fonctionnement s'ils
engagements sont tenus je vais vous
assurer sur un point l'autonomie du
maire est pleinement respectée l'État ne
fait que l'accompagner dans la mise en
oeuvre de ces contrats la vague de
contrat en cours est dotée de 30
millions d'euros répartis sur 2021 2023
nous pouvons par ailleurs répondre à
votre volonté d'élargir ces contrats à
plus de communes puisque l'Assemblée
nationale a voté cette année 30 millions
d'euros supplémentaires pour les Corum
en 2023 cela devra nous permettre
d'amplifier ce dispositif
d'accompagnement des collectivités qui
nous le croyons fait largement consensus
et je vous remercie de l'avoir rappelé
dans votre question vous le voyez madame
la sénatrice le gouvernement agit et
continuera à travailler s'autorité de la
en lien avec les maires ultramarins pour
accompagner leur volonté d'assurer une
gestion saine de leur finance meilleur
moyen de leur donner des marges de
manœuvre supplémentaires dans l'exercice
de leur mission auprès de nos
concitoyens d'outre-mer
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre fraugier pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre
le 28 octobre dernier
s'est tenu à Matignon sous votre
autorité
une réunion dite convention des
partenaires
consacrée à l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie
en cette circonstance vous avez rappelé
avec raison qu'à l'issue du processus
référendaire l'avenir appartient
désormais au calédonien et qui leur
revenait d'élaborer un projet d'avenir
consensuel
pour y parvenir vous avez proposé la
mise en place de groupes de travail que
le ministre de l'Intérieur est des
Outre-mer doit installer lors de sa
visite dans les jours prochains à Nouméa
cette initiative est utile
puisqu'elle s'inscrit dans le choix que
la Nouvelle-Calédonie a fait de rester
français
mais c'est elle suffisante
les référendums de 2018 2020 2021 on non
seulement ravivé les tensions les
divisions mais ont réduit en miettes
cette exception calédonienne symbolisée
par cette fameuse poignée de mains
que ce sont donnés Jacques Lafleur et
Jean-Marie chibaou en 1988
de partenaires madame la Première
ministre nous sommes redevenus des
adversaires
j'en veux pour preuve l'absence des
mouvements indépendantistes à cette
convention dite des partenaires et
pourtant
pour élaborer ce projet d'avenir
consensuel que vous appelez vous-même de
vos vœux nous n'avons pas d'autres choix
que de renouer ces liens de confiance
car notre avenir ne se construira pas
sans l'autre ni contre l'autre
concrètement quelles initiatives le
ministre de l'Intérieur envisage-t-il de
prendre lors de son séjour à Nouméa pour
que les trois partenaires qui étaient
l'État les indépendantistes et nous nous
retrouvions en confiance merci
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre porte parole du gouvernement
monsieur Véran merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur Frogier
le déplacement officiel prévue la
semaine prochaine en Nouvelle-Calédonie
fait suite à l'organisation vous l'avez
dit de la Convention des partenaires qui
s'est réunit le 28 octobre dernier à la
demande de la première ministre vous y
étiez d'ailleurs monsieur le sénateur
comme vous le savez le lancement de la
Convention des partenaires a marqué le
début des discussions sur l'avenir
institutionnel de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
au terme du processus politique des
phonie dans l'Accord de Nouméa le
processus de définition d'un projet pour
la Nouvelle-Calédonie qui consacre sa
place dans la République française et
respecte ces singularités et désormais
engagé si les échanges du 28 octobre ont
été dans ces fructueux ils ont été
incomplets pour vous en avez été témoin
monsieur le sénateur en raison notamment
de l'absence d'une partie des forces
politiques or pour que le processus que
nous avons engagé aboutissent toutes les
forces politiques calédoniennes doivent
y contribuer
le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer se rend donc en
Nouvelle-Calédonie accompagnée du
ministre chargé des outre-mer pour
prendre le temps du dialogue et de
l'écoute afin que tous les partenaires
politiques participent aux discussions
dans un esprit de responsabilité et de
consensus dans cette démarche monsieur
le sénateur le gouvernement sait qu'il
pourra compter sur votre engagement
personnel sur votre capacité à nouer le
dialogue avec les responsables
indépendantistes mais les discussions
ouvertes par la Convention des
partenaires ont également vocations à
traiter de sujets stratégiques pour
l'avenir décalédoniens au-delà des
sujets institutionnels qui feront
l'objet de discussion Haddock plusieurs
groupes de travail seront organisés sur
les sujets suivants égalité des chances
et coecession sociale développement
économique emploi grands investissements
nickel souveraineté énergétique et
transition écologique souveraineté
alimentaire fonciers valeur
identité commune et Réconciliation
intégration et rayonnement régional dans
ce contexte le déplacement du ministre
lui permettra également de rencontrer la
société civile la les acteurs
économiques ou associatifs de nouvelles
Calédonie pour comprendre les enjeux
leurs attentes leur permettre de
contribuer à la définition d'un projet
qui intéresse d'abord l'ensemble des
Calédoniens
la parole est à notre
la parole est notre collègue Annick
billon pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à la
madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères Alain mon veille de la
Journée internationale de la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
deux mois après la mort de Macha Amini
la situation des droits et liberté des
femmes dans le monde est extrêmement
préoccupante en Afghanistan les talibans
ni les femmes en Ukraine des femmes sont
violées et subissent des violences
sexuelles de l'envahisseur russe en
République démocratique du Congo en
Syrie en Éthiopie en République
centrafricaine au Soudan au Yémen en
Birmanie le viol est utilisé comme arme
de guerre les minorités Yezidis oui ne
sont pas plus épargnés en Iran la
répression est terrible une répression
contre les femmes bien sûr car c'est le
combat qui est mené par les manifestants
de la liberté mais plus largement une
répression contre l'humanité dans le cas
de l'Iran nous pouvons agir nous devons
agir mais nous ne le faisons pas ou pas
assez l'Iran préside la commission
onusienne de la condition de la femme
qu'elle s'ynisme notre collègue Marly
Marie Arlette Carlotti a déjà soulevé le
paradoxe le 9 novembre dernier le
gouvernement s'est dit impuissant
avons-nous été impuissants quand la
Russie a attaqué l'Ukraine non nous ne
l'avons pas été nous ne nous sommes pas
résignés contre l'Iran les sanctions
n'empêche pas la violence envers les
manifestants femme vit liberté madame la
ministre le slogan des femmes iraniennes
imposent à la France de s'élever contre
la barbarie d'emola et cela passe par la
dénonciation de cette présidente
onusienne de la condition de la femme
par l'Iran qu'attendez-vous quand
cesserez-vous de mettre un voile sur la
condition des femmes en Iran
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice billon
femme
vit liberté face aux aspirations
légitimes des iraniennes et des Iraniens
le régime a choisi la voix de la
répression ce que nous avons condamné et
continuons de condamner de la façon la
plus claire
chaque jour de nouvelles victimes plus
de 300 déjà des jeunes femmes comme
Massa mini 22 ans des enfants comme Kian
la pirefalac 9 ans et cela dure depuis
10 semaines
il faut ajouter les arrestations les
détentions la censure et les pressions
contre les artistes les avocats les
journalistes ou les simples citoyens
la France soutient les aspirations des
iraniennes et des Iraniens a plus de
liberté le président de la République
vous le savez à rencontrer le 11
novembre plusieurs iraniennes exilés
visage de la lutte pour la liberté et
pour les valeurs universelles et j'ai
dit moi-même mon soutien alors qu'en bas
à plusieurs reprises à la représentation
nationale devant la presse ou par vidéo
donc j'espère qu'on a pu les voir en
Iran et notre action se décline dans
toutes les enceintes internationales à
l'Union européenne qui a pris plusieurs
sanctions à plusieurs reprises contre
les responsables de la répression à
l'ONU ou le Conseil des droits de
l'homme demain jeudi examinera la
situation en Iran et créera un mécanisme
de suivi un mécanisme d'établissement
des faits pour que la vérité puisse être
dite et nous serons vigilants aussi
madame la sénatrice pour que l'Iran ne
puisse pas détourner la Commission de la
condition de la femme des Nations Unies
de son objet et enfin nous continuerons
de demander nous continuerons de
demander à l'Iran de cesser leur
répression de respecter le droit de
manifester pacifiquement et bien sûr de
libérer immédiatement nos compatriotes
retenus en otage je vous remercie
la parole est que l'autre collègue
François Calvet pour le groupe les
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Madame
s'adresser à madame la ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
l'article 72 de la Constitution garantit
la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales et donc des
communes cellules de base de la
démocratie mais vu d'en haut les
communes ne seraient qu'un échelon
administratif alors que dans les faits
on les a vu pendant la crise du covid
les communes et leurs élus se ont été
les plus proches de nos concitoyens en
première ligne or à quoi siste t-on
depuis plusieurs années à une véritable
mise sous tutelle des mers qui sous
couvert de soi-disant loi de
décentralisation ne dispose plus
d'aucune autonomie fiscale l'État a
progressivement supprimé les impôts
locaux dans les communes fixées
librement le taux pour les remplacer par
des et des impôts nationaux partagés et
que dire des fameux contrats de Cahors
et du soi-disant pacte de confiance que
le gouvernement veut imposer à toute
force comme le constatent l’économiste
Michel cabanes la garantie
constitutionnelle de l'autonomie
financière n'est plus qu'une façade et
comme le dit Philippe Laurent
vice-président de la MF ce que veut
l'État au fond c'est la suppression de
la fiscalité locale ce que les mœurs les
mers peuvent retenir eux c'est que ce
jacobinisme cette recentralisation de
moins en moins déguisé des notes le peu
de considération que l'État pour eux et
le mépris dans lequel les tient quand le
gouvernement se décidera-t-il
entreprendre une vraie réforme fiscale
qui redonnera dignité confiance au maire
premier élu du peuple
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué on cherche de
l'industrie monsieur roller Lescure
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs sénatrices monsieur le
sénateur Calvet je voudrais d'abord vous
prier d'excuser le ministre Gabriel etal
qui est retenu à l'Assemblée pour la
lecture des conclusions d'un commission
mix paritaire sur le projet de loi de
finances rectangle rectificatif et le
ministre Bruno Le Maire qui représente
la France à la Conférence ministérielle
de l'agence européenne spatiale ce qui
explique ma présence pour vous pour vous
répondre aujourd'hui monsieur le
sénateur ce qui me permettra peut-être
de prendre un angle un peu différent des
réponses déjà complètes qui ont été
faites par madame la Première ministre
et mon collègue Olivier Klein
l'autonomie fiscale vous l'avez vous le
savez les garanties par la Constitution
de 2003 les collectivités territoriales
longs et en aucun cas depuis 2003 la
part des impôts dans les recettes des
collectivités territoriales n'a été
diminuée pour autant vous l'avez dit
nous avons souhaité baisser un certain
nombre d'impôts de production et nous
continuons à le faire et même s'il Sénat
je le regrette à décaler d'un an la
suppression de la CVAE je tiens à
rappeler à nos dames et messieurs les
signatures les raisons pour lesquelles
nous l'avons fait aujourd'hui les impôts
de production c'est encore quatre fois
plus en France qu'en Allemagne c'est
deux fois plus en France que dans
l'ensemble de la zone euro le ministre
l'industrie que je souhaite souhaite
continuer à réindustrialiser la France
nous devons le faire notamment dans
cette période extrêmement compliquée de
hausse des coûts de l'énergie et oui
cela passe par une réduction des impôts
de production locaux est-ce que pour
autant nous affaiblissons les recettes
des collectivités locales la réponse est
non
non parce que vous le savez nous nous
compensons cette baisse de la fiscalité
par une part des recettes de la TVA qui
permettait moi de vous le rappeler et
plus dynamique que la CVA la TVA depuis
10 ans c'est 3,5 % de rose des recettes
tous les ans contre 2,5 contre la CVAE
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs les
collectivités territoriales vont y
gagner est-ce que pour autant nous
devons pour autant réduire les
incitations des collectivités
territoriales à la réindustrialisation
la réponse est non nous créons un fond
d'attractivité industriel vous le savez
il sera doté de on va le construire
ensemble monsieur le sénateur il sera
doté de 250 millions 2023 jusqu'à 650
millions pour conclure
ensemble les critères qui nous
permettront ensemble de réindustrialiser
pour conclure
quelques secondes
Satan c'est que peut-être il y a des
augmentations de DGF si vous qui le
dites mais nous ce que nous constatons
2007 40 milliards des GF 2023 26
milliards 27 milliards de GF 12
milliards de moins voilà ce qui se passe
et par ailleurs nous nous voulons une
autonomie parce que nous travaillons
pour le service public local et nous
voulons l'autonomie financière et le
respect de nos élus locaux
la parole est à notre collègue Viviane
artiguelas pour le groupe socialistes
écologistes et républicains
merci le ministre le pacte de confiance
se désigne le nouveau dispositif de
limitation des dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités
proposées par le gouvernement mais
derrière cette formule on distingue très
nettement l'esprit des contrats de
Cahors empire tentez si bien que sur le
terrain il est renommé pacte de défiance
la démarche du gouvernement se vit dans
les territoires qu'ils soient de
banlieue urbains ou ruraux comme une
recentralisation diffuse du
fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales dont l'état grignote de
plus en plus les prérogatives la
transformation des impôts locaux directs
en compensation supprime la fiscalité
des namique des communes et entraîne une
dépense financière à l'état et la
volonté sous-jacente de prendre la main
sur les politiques locales cet état
d'esprit Jacobins remet en cause le
principe constitutionnel de libre
administration des collectivités alors
que le gouvernement se dit engagé dans
un nouvel acte de décentralisation les
services de l'État nationalement et
visiblement sur interprète souvent les
textes ou règlements au détriment des
exécutifs locaux auparavant l'état
accompagné les maires pour réaliser
leurs projets mais nous sommes passés à
l'injonction sur la méthode aux gens
suis aujourd'hui nous en sommes à la
contrainte les mères ne sont pas les
simples exécutants des priorités de
l'État monsieur le ministre allez-vous
favoriser l'accompagnement des
collectivités leur faire confiance et
stopper cette mise à mal du principe de
décentralisation voulue par la loi de
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégués
en charge de la ville et du logement
vous avez la parole monsieur Klein
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Viviane
d'abord pour compléter ce que vient de
dire mon collègue Roland Lescure la plus
belle autonomie fiscale d'amer c'est
faire celle que j'ai fait pendant 11 ans
c'est-à-dire baisser systématiquement
les impôts et ne jamais les augmenter et
tenir mes engagements
sur le
pacte de confiance le gouvernement a
fait le choix d'introduire le pacte de
confiance dans le PLF 2023 sous la forme
d'un rapport du Gouvernement au
Parlement tous les acteurs publics états
comme collectivité territoriale doivent
participer à l'effort collectif pour
établir les comptes de la nation il en
va de la crédibilité de notre pays
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires européens
c'est le sens des trajectoires
budgétaires inscrites en loi de
programmation des finances publiques
nous serons bien sûr attentifs au débat
qui seront les vôtres ici au Sénat sur
ce sujet et vous savez que le
gouvernement est à l'écoute des
collectivités territoriales et donc de
vous-même qui se porte leur position sur
la suppression de la CVAE une
suppression qui aura lieu en deux ans
qui s'accompagne évidemment d'une
compensation pour les collectivités
concernées bloc communal et départements
et la compensation a fait l'objet de
nombreux échanges avec les associations
d'élus en particulier l'ADF sur la
partie départementale le PLF 2023
prévoit donc actuellement et ça a été
rappelé il y a quelques minutes à l'euro
près de la compensation à le retrait
pardon de la part de la TVA dynamique et
par ailleurs l'État conservera ne
conservera pas un euro de la CVAE qui
aurait dû être versé au collectivités en
2023 la TVA sera territorisé pour le
bloc communal et forfaitisé pour les
départements comme je l'ai rappelé tout
à l'heure enfin elle ne réduit pas
l'autonomie des collectivités nous
passons un système à une CVAE nationale
d'une CVA nationale qui était repartie
souvent des critères de stérilisation un
système à un autre impôt national et non
une dotation qui serait répartie selon
des critères concernés merci
monsieur le ministre vous rendez pas
compte qu'il est nécessaire de faire
confiance aux élus locaux le président
de la République lui-même s'est engagé
le 10 octobre amené une vraie
décentralisation il vous reste à passer
aux actes cela passe par une grande loi
sur les libertés locales et surtout les
moyens qui vont avec selon le principe
le simple du qui décide paye et qui paye
décide si vous souhaitez
réindustrialiser nos territoires et à
sucer assurer la transition écologique
dans notre pays il vous faut entendre
les élus locaux car vous ne pourrez pas
faire sans eux ils demeure
incontournable comme la démontrer la
gestion de la crise sanitaire
et la parole est à notre collègue
Catherine belriti pour le groupe les
républicains vous avez la parole
monsieur chers collègues
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre chers collègues la sécheresse
historique de cet été nous rappelle
combien la question de la gestion de la
ressource en eau est essentiel pour
notre pays à cet effet le Sénat rendra
cette semaine un rapport dans lequel
nous définissons des priorités pour
éviter d'être demain dans une situation
encore plus difficile que celle
d'aujourd'hui nous nous interrogeons
toutefois sur les motivations du
gouvernement à agir concrètement pour
être en phase avec les attentes des
territoires en matière de couvertance
tout d'abord le Sénat s'est prononcé sur
la nécessité de préserver la souplesse
d'un transfert facultatif de la
compétence en eau de la commune vers les
intercommunalités cela pour une raison
très simple l'eau répond à une logique
de bassin versant et non de périmètre
intercommunal il est également une autre
évidence se transfère rendu obligatoire
d'ici 2026 a et va générer une
augmentation significative du prix de
l'eau pour l'usager
s'agissant de la question des ressources
financières là encore vous vous
détournez de vos obligations lors du
débat sur le financement des agences de
l'eau au Sénat en janvier le
gouvernement avait pris l'engagement de
présenter les grands axes de leur futur
financement elles ont subi labaissement
de leur plafond de recettes en 2018 et
se voit ponctionner une part importante
de leur budget notamment par l'Office
français de la biodiversité de fait
comme cela avait déjà été exprimé nous
redoutons que contrairement aux
principes fondateurs l'eau ne paye plus
l'eau mais l'eau paye l'État comme
souvent vos choix ou plutôt vos absences
de décision mettent à mal nos
territoires ma question est donc simple
madame la Première ministre allez-vous
entendre la voix des territoires qui
demandent plus de liberté dans la
gouvernance de l'eau et plus de moyens
pour agir
monsieur le ministre de la Ville et du
logement
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame lassenatrice belretti
la loi notre de 2015 transfert
effectivement la compétence de l'eau et
de l'assainissement aux EPCI à fiscalité
propre et depuis le 2018 les EPCI ont
aussi la compétence germatique et
doivent à ce titre gérer les ouvrages de
protection contre les inondations dans
une période transitoire qui doit
permettre de laisser aux acteurs le
temps de s'organiser l'étagère certains
ouvrages jusqu'en 2024
ce transfert représentera indéniablement
des investissements importants pour les
collectivités là encore j'en sais
quelque chose puisque j'appartiens le PC
dans le bassin versant vert sur la Marne
et nous avons des obligations dans le
cadre des Jeux olympiques de 2024 et
nous les tiendrons
plusieurs outils financiers sont
déployés pour les accompagner le fonds
de prévention des risques majeurs
naturels
appuyer jusqu'en 2027 les études et les
travaux sur les anciennes digues de
l'État l'attaque gemapi qui permet de
prélever jusqu'à 40 euros par habitant 2
milliards d'euros au titre des
financements des agences de l'eau et du
dispositif aquap-près géré par la Caisse
des Dépôts la loi 3DS permet en outre
une expérimentation destinée à mieux
associer les établissements publics
territoriaux de bassins à cette
politique par des financements dédiés
elle permet enfin aux EPCI de se
regrouper dans des structures dédiées
afin d'atteindre la bonne échelle de
gestion hydrographique l'état accompagne
donc les collectivités dans ce transfert
l'État et ça a déjà été ici par mon
collègue Christophe Béchu et par
Bérengère Couillard sera très attentif à
la gestion de l'eau et à la capacité
d'avoir de l'eau dans toutes les
communes de France les moyens et les
capacités financières ouvertes sont donc
importante tout comme les leviers de
gouvernance je vous remercie
nous réaffirmons que la décision de
transférer ou non la compétence de l'eau
vers un syndicat ou intercommunalité
doit rester celle de la commune par
ailleurs sans préservation de moyens de
financement des agences de l'eau il
n'est pas envisageable de pouvoir
relever les défis de demain en matière
de gestion de la ressource et le pire
est à redouter encore un domaine dans
lequel les collectivités territoriales
se sentent sacrifiées merci la parole
est à notre collègue Stéphane de Billy
pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
le gouvernement souhaite un dialogue
apaisé avec les élus mais un nouveau
signal complètement inverse leur a été
envoyé dans le projet de loi de finance
en cours d'examen en effet lors des
débats l'Assemblée nationale le
gouvernement a déposé discrètement un
amendement revenant sur les modalités de
la participation de l'État et de France
compétences au financement de
l'apprentissage dans la fonction
publique territoriale pourtant ce
financement faisait l'objet d'un accord
entre le gouvernement le CNFPT et les
employeurs territoriaux un accord qui
prévoyait que sur les 80 millions
d'euros que coûte la formation de
l'apprentissage la moitié soit payée par
une cotisation des collectivités 15
millions par l'État 15 autres par France
compétences et le solde par le CNFPT
cet accord d'octobre 21 uneaniement
salué par les associations d'élus a fait
l'objet d'une signature officielle en
janvier et est intégrée dans le code
général de la Fonction publique par cet
accord le gouvernement se féliciter
d'ailleurs à l'époque je cite de
disposer à compter de 2022 d'un mode de
financement pérenne j'insiste sur le mot
incitatif au recrutement d'apprentis par
les collectivités territoriales mais ça
c'était avant comme dans la pub d'une
célèbre marque de lunettes car dans
l'exposé de l'amendement déposé adopté
grâce aux 49-3 il y a peu à l'Assemblée
nationale on évoque cette fois-ci je
cite des financements complémentaires et
exceptionnels de l'État et de France
compétences qui n'ont pas vocation à
être pérenne madame la ministre on a
vraiment du mal à s'y retrouver les
budgets municipaux sont déjà compliqués
à boucléons à évoqué tout à l'heure si
les engagements de l'État bougent au gré
du vent et au gré des ministres comment
voulez-vous que les collectivités
s'engagent avec assurance dans un tel
processus de recrutement d'apprentis
madame la ministre l'apprentissage est
une excellente approche pour former le
jeûne dans notre pays que ce soit dans
le public ou que ce soit dans le privé
encore faut-il avoir un peu de
visibilité et permettez-moi de le dire
en toute amitié vous le savez un peu de
constance dans nos politiques de
l'emploi pour vous répondre la parole de
la télévision en charge de lampe de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle madame Grandjean vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Stéphane
Demy merci effectivement pour cette
question qui nous permet de reprendre un
certain nombre d'éléments je voudrais
d'abord excuser l'absence de Stanislas
Guerini qui participe actuellement au
conseil d'administration de l'infp et
qui n'a pas donc pu être présent
aujourd'hui alors vous le soulignez
monsieur le sénateur l'apprentissage est
effectivement un formidable levier
d'insertion pour les jeunes et nous
sommes évidemment pleinement tous
convaincus ici qu'il en estint également
pour la fonction publique et nous
souhaitons soutenir l'apprentissage dans
la fonction publique pour promouvoir les
parcours de carrière et l'attractivité
de la fonction publique
alors l'état c'est formidablement engagé
autour de l'apprentissage et notamment
autour de l'apprentissage dans les
collectivités territoriales et pour
amorcer l'apprentissage dans la fonction
publique à appuyer financièrement les
collectivités territoriales avec 15
milliards 15 millions pardon d'euros
engagés par l'État et 15 millions
d'euros engagés par France compétences
en 2022 cela a porté ses fruits et je
tiens à le souligner puisque l'objectif
de 8000 apprentis qui était fixés
ensemble à largement été dépassé et que
12000 apprentis ont été recrutés dans la
fonction publique c'est donc sans
contexte sans conteste un véritable
succès que nous pouvons tous saluer ici
et saluer l'engagement des collectivités
en tant qu'employeur pour favoriser
l'attractivité de leur métier et de ses
parcours de carrière je voudrais dire
que cela a fonctionné aussi parce que
nous avons souhaité prolonger encore
cette disposition à un amendement du
Gouvernement au travers de la loi de
finances à apporter une garantie d'un
engagement en 2023 supplémentaire donc à
nouveau 15 millions d'euros de l'État et
15 millions d'euros de France
compétences je rappelle notamment au
travers des cotisations des entreprises
cela nous donnera donc du temps en 2023
pour une discussion sereine et
constructive avec l'ensemble des
associations d'élus et le CNFPT sur les
modalités de financement à venir pour
l'apprentissage dans les collectivités
nous devons travailler sur cette
attractivité ces parcours et c'est donc
tous ensemble que nous réfléchissons en
2023 sur les modalités de financement à
venir
nous avons terminé avec les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres merci je vous rappelle que
les prochaines questions auront lieu le
mercredi 7 décembre à 15h je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h40 pour la suite de l'examen de la
première partie du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 la séance est
suspendue